[Music]
the wonder of the foundation a short
educational video brought to you by the
SCP foundation
[Music]
welcome doctors researchers and
scientists first of all let me give you
a brief introduction as to who we are
most of this information is classified
but the broad strokes are this we are a
global organization that protects
humanity from terrible events that's it
as you can imagine science is at the
forefront of everything we do so in
essence we need the best humanity has to
offer to protect humanity to the best of
our ability I can also tell you that you
have never heard of us before any
preconceived notions about who or what
we are before you started listening to
me forget them so your curiosity is
piqued but you have no idea the
discoveries that exist behind our doors
will you unlock this door of imagination
because beyond it is another world
another reality and once you can immerse
yourself in it you will look back at
your previous life and think why has it
taken so long for me to reach my true
call it working with us you will find
colleagues equipment and test subjects
beyond anything you've seen or even
dreamt enough
you're probably thinking you've made it
you've reached the top of the mountain
right wrong doctor
because this is where your journey
begins you are on the precipice of
discovery once you have been processed
and enrolled officially you can start to
serve the foundation but more
importantly yourself working with us is
just as much of a personal journey as it
is a professional one
the doctors researchers and scientists
that the foundation currently employs
are nothing like what they were before
they stood where you are today
some have became unrecognizable their
former selves shadows in the light of
their newfound inside creatures of awe
and mystery objects that will perplex
the most brilliant human mind places a
pool challenge or skepticism to its
limits
and pathogens that will defy the very
nature of science itself here at the
foundation we are making reality
shattering discoveries every single day
and we want you all to be a part of it
if you're interested and I know you are
apply for a research position at the
foundation today and say goodbye to your
old life completely the foundation is
your family now you'll be safe with us
doctor
[Music]
you